l'attelage se prépare doucement ce lundi
10 janvier les quatre boulonnais les
deux percherons sont à nouveau sur le
pont depuis le vendredi 7 janvier les
équipages ramasse les sapins de noël on
les choisit pour l'heure pour leurs
aptitudes déjà physique puisqu'ils se
sont des chevaux qui sont un petit peu
plus costauds sont des chevaux de trait
donc qu'ils sont un petit peu plus
costaud que la moyenne pour tirer des
charges relativement lourde quand même
avec les sapins sam équipes et des
remords qui tout cela et puis surtout
pour l'heure leurs capacités mentales
qui sont des animaux froid très très
bien dans leur tête et qui sont des
vrais compagnons et des collègues de
travail de tous les jours trois
attelages se répartissent les
différentes rues de la ville selon les
secteurs c'est la sixième année
consécutive que la mairie fait le choix
de ce type de ramassage on faisait d'une
pierre deux coups parce que d'une part
on collecte avec les chevaux d'autre
part après avoir broyé les sapins on
utilise le broyat dans les espaces verts
de la ville
ce que l'on a constaté c'est une
augmentation d'année après année où les
gens se sont fait à ce procédé et il
apprécie énormément les attelages
travaillent environ cinq heures par jour
en une heure cet équipage composé de
trois cochet de deux chevaux ont déjà
récupéré près d'une centaine de sapins
et ne laisse pas les habitants
insensible pour sa bien d'une part parce
que les gens jettent pas leur sapin
n'importe où je trouve ça très bien que
ce soit organisé
je pense que c'est que c'est une trop
dur très bonne idée c'est écologique
voilà j'espère que ce n'est pas trop
lourd pour les joies c'est tout à
maisons laffitte le ramassage continue
jusqu'au 11 janvier l'an dernier les
équipes avaient récupéré 2007 sans armes
la collecte devrait être du même niveau
en 2022